are you ready to
maybe smoke some green
i can't say i'm on the clock yeah on the
clock anyway
you know who's ready to smoke some green
mike tyson
cannabis is giving this this dude some
high
returns you know how much money this guy
apparently makes a month from cannabis
what's that a million bucks a month
million bucks a month mike tyson
cannabis can you believe this million
bucks a month yeah iron mike kind of
redonkulous iron mic iron mic you might
need a new nickname yeah hi mike hi mike
right this is better i can come up some
better give me a second yeah he's not
low mike that's for sure
so iron mike is all in on cannabis and
it's raking in cash mike tyson's latest
transformation as a legal drug dealer
could set him up for life the former
heavyweight champ has been selling
cannabis products since 2016 through his
tyson holistic
label that is as potent as one of his
uppercuts let me tell you something if
if
the weed is as potent as one of his
uppercuts i don't want that one yeah i
think i'm good i'm good good the last
thing i needed was just get knocked
knocked out
you're just gonna knock the [ __ ] out
thanks mike
all right go easy on the on on that
tyson holistic anyway so tyson's i think
he's like uh early 53 i believe he earns
again a million bucks a month
through his business offering uh
marijuana premium
strains edibles extracts whatever comes
with that and that's just the tip of the
iceberg david that's just that's just
the tip
pause so tyson also invested his dough
in chill a company that makes cbd
alkaline water he believes that cbd can
help fight opiate addiction as well as
provide leave from pain and arthritis i
actually agree with that
opioid opioid not that we need to go
down this path the opioid pandemic in
this country is real yeah and you know
if athletes or non-athletes even
can use cbd or even cannabis way better
than pills popping pills ain't the
answer so i actually respect mike on
this i actually respect that he's doing
something on this and he's making some
serious loot
he is
he is breaking one rule though what's
that you know how they biggie said
never get high on your own supply
now i i had to re-read this number and
then re-read it again
he confessed to smoking 82 000 of his
own supply
every month every month every
month dude what okay never get high on
your own supply but who's going to tell
mike tyson what to do yeah exactly you
know pbd interviewed um
yeah tyson recently i met him the
opportunity to spend some time backstage
with him
guy reeked of weed did he really
straight up that's 82 000 worth of yes
he showed up he had this driver cool guy
young guy strapped
tyson showed up i don't know if he was
high the driver tyson was high [ __ ]
patty interviewed him
i i go hey mike um let's take a picture
bro yeah sure yeah you put out his hand
like like this yeah shake my hand you
know people should have a picture i go
hey mike uh
why don't we take a picture you know
like this you know he goes come on man
peace man i ain't trying to fight you
i'm not trying to fight you bro
i'm like you know what mike i respect
that i respect you i respect that bro
so anyway never get high on your own
supply but mike will do what he wants to
do but he did smell of weed but if he's
making a million bucks a weed smell
however you want mike yeah however you
want yeah um
on top of that he is building a weed
themed holiday resort theme park type of
thing with a tyson university on site
that will aim to teach people about the
cannabis cultivation
that is going on in mike tyson's world
dude
is there i i want to just can you
imagine anyone that's been convicted of
possession of marijuana yeah
and then they're watching this right now
like mike tyson makes a million dollars
and he gets high eighty two thousand
dollars and he's got a weed [ __ ]
like conservatory
here's something here's something
hopefully this message gets the mic
mike you're making all this money
you've been in jail you've been
convicted of stuff you've made a name
for yourself
i think the next step with mike
right
make your money on cannabis awesome
great
use your voice there's a lot of people
in jail
because of what you're getting rich on
right now yeah use your voice get these
people out of jail i'm not saying you
got to get political i'm not saying you
need to be republican democrat whatever
i think we all agree that people sitting
in jail rotting for years
because of the drug
uh uh
crackdown yeah in the 90s the war on
drugs thank you uh has landed people
selling pot
decades in jail i think mike tyson can
use his voice for the good of society
for the good of these people and make
money while you're at it yeah and see
the other side of that coin is like well
yeah it's legal now when people are
making millions but i mean they also
broke that law that rule at that time at
that time so it's like dude i'm sorry
which is retroactive yeah exactly
retroactive
anyway that's my advice to mike not that
he needs my advice i would love to see
him do something like that could you
imagine mike tyson being an advocate for
criminal reform
that's being an advocate for cannabis
i think that's got legs who says no and
like you said who says
tyson listen uh mr supreme court justice
i'm gonna knock you the [ __ ] out if uh
and parole officers i'm just gonna have
you
let it be known uh that my dude over
here he's going to get out of jail he's
going to walk away scot-free
and um then we're going to get high
smoke a joint dude i think that's a
great i want him to be
uh smoking a joint not in the joint
can we can we make that happen
signed
mike tyson
p.s i'll bite your [ __ ] face
anyway i think mike tyson would be great
yeah um
so
mike tyson making a killing on cannabis
respect to you
all we mike is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken